thinking about the reasons why you train
is often as important as thinking about
how you train where you train or
anything else now it's not my place to
tell you that you're training for the
wrong reason there is no wrong reason to
train if you're exercising at all that's
great we all have our own reasons for
wanting to work out however what I can
say is that if you're training
predominantly to impress other people
especially members of the opposite sex
then chances are that not only is it not
going to work but to borrow a phrase
from Jeff Cavalier you're probably
destroying your gains now of course I'm
not saying that it's a bad thing to have
aesthetic gold of course wanting to look
your best and sculpt your body is a
really Noble pursuit in many cases all
I'm saying is that a that probably
shouldn't be your only goal and B you
need to make sure you're doing it for
the right reasons you need to make sure
you're doing it for you because if
you're trying to impress other people
you should know other people are never
impressed and here's the issue when you
train to impress other people and this
is one of the reasons I implore you not
to do this you're going to focus
predominantly on your mirror muscles so
your mirror muscles are things like the
shoulders the pecs the the ABS to an
extent biceps all the things that people
can see we call them the mirror muscles
because they're also the things that we
see when we look in the mirror however
if you just train those things you're
going to be very much hunched over front
heavy leg weak and as a result you're
not going to be very balanced you're not
going to be very functional you're
compounding an issue you've already got
you're ignoring Mobility because that's
not going to impress the ladies that's
not going to impress your mates and the
result is that you end up actually
causing more harm and this is a problem
if you want to trade for longevity for
performance Etc and I do think that
training for performance and Longevity
Etc is ultimately healthier to be
absolutely clear I'm not claiming that
I'm immune to all of this far from it
when I was younger being the strong guy
at school certainly became a part of my
identity and later on at University I
eventually got obsessed with building
bigger biceps and pecs and getting a
stronger bench press at the expense of
some of the things that mattered more to
me personally ultimately like my
Mobility my ability to run and jump and
climb and for martial arts I let those
Fall by the wayside so I could chase
after those more superficial gains and
these days I'm trying to run a YouTube
channel and being strong in a thumbnail
is a great way to get clicks and likes
I'm now trying to impress the entire
world what that says about my psychology
is probably best left unexamined however
for a lot of people this actually goes
deeper they train because they feel
maybe sidelined because they feel maybe
smaller and weaker and they want to
become this Alpha they feel ignored by
the opposite sex or whoever they find
attractive and they want to build muscle
so they look more impressive so they can
attract those people and as such it
becomes this desperate desire to train
themselves and again these are good
things but if it's coming from a place
of insecurity then it can actually just
lead to toxicity self-loathing this is
really the reason I wanted to make this
video because of this channel is
something of a self-help Channel as well
a self-improvement self-development
channel I'm not just interested in
building muscles you guys now I'm also
interested in brain function and all
kinds of other stuff and so I do
consider some of these self-development
channels to be you know my
contemporaries and a lot of them are
putting forth this idea that if you want
to attract members of the opposite sex
if you want to be powerful and feel
great and have everyone look up to you
then you need to build loads of muscle
but that's not the case building loads
of muscle will not make you into an
alpha male will not make you the leader
of the pack will not stop you getting
teased it won't help you to impress
members of the opposite sex as I
jokingly commented in the previous video
it's not your muscles that's a problem
it's your personality it's a little bit
harsh and of course I'm joking but there
is also a element of Truth in it because
yeah it's not your muscle that's
preventing you from being the leader of
the pack because we know for starters
that being the strongest person doesn't
even make you the greatest fighter I am
stronger than Grant I can bench press
much more than him but he would kick my
ass in a fight for countless reasons he
can generate more power he's faster he's
got better reflexes it's not me or him
who would necessarily take on the more
dominant role in a group moreover it's
the person who's more willing to a
manipulate other people which isn't a
particularly nice trait but it does go a
long way or potentially the person who's
willing to upset other people or to
punch him in the face if you are
interested in trying to impress your
friend and members of the opposite sex
then you might be interested in trying
to look after your appearance but again
I think we need to look at this from
another angle we should look after our
skin and our appearance not to try and
impress other people but because it's
important for the way we feel about
ourselves and for our health especially
as we get older again this is something
where you're going to look back and wish
that you've taken it seriously which is
why I'm really proud to say that today's
sponsor is tiege Hanley long time
sponsors of the channel who've been
fantastic to work with teach Hanley
simplifies the process of taking care of
your skin by providing you with set
packs and instruction cards you get a
regular selection of creams and
ointments sent to you depending on which
ones you choose as well as an
instruction card that shows you exactly
how and when to apply each one it really
takes the guesswork out and makes it
very easy to look after your skin I
recommend starting with a level 1 system
which comes with all the basics a daily
face wash and exfoliating scrub an AM
moisturizer with SPF 20 and a PM
moisturizer I'm really happy with the
product and I love using them and I
think I've seen some great results but
it's not just me either they have over 7
000 5 Star reviews from around the world
teach Handley members get loads of
benefits including 20 or more off the
retail price the ability to pause or
cancel at any time and free us shipping
and because teach Hanley is sponsoring
today's video they're offering my
viewers a great deal just click the
first link in the description box and
you'll get 30 off your first box plus a
free gift don't miss out on this amazing
deal click that link and get started
today thanks again to teach Hanley for
sponsoring this video and now on with
the show because ultimately the deciding
factor in most confrontations is
psychology so it doesn't matter how many
weights you can lift you're not
instantly going to become the most
dominant person and you can't fake that
kind of aggression that kind of
Detachment and you shouldn't want that
anyways these aren't great traits this
can happen on a macro Cosmic global
scale where guys want status generally
could also happen in a microcosm where
people want status within their group
this can happen where someone isn't
particularly happy they start
powerlifting or they start martial arts
and they start to progress there and
impress that small group but ultimately
again just trying to impress other
people is a hollow Pursuit that isn't
going to result the most well-rounded
you and it's not always the most
muscular guy who attracts the opposite
sex either now in this next part of the
video I take a little bit of a sidebar
to talk about something that I have no
experience in really no Authority
certainly and no right to talk about I
call this segment the bioneers love
corner and I'm going to describe what I
think is the problem with dating advice
for men in particular so there's kind of
this notion online that the nice guys
finish last and that the Chads get all
the ladies and that you need to be a
little bit assertive and dominant if
you're going to attract anybody and that
anyone who says otherwise is just
kidding themselves I honestly think this
couldn't be further from the truth the
problem with most nice guys isn't that
they're too nice it's the fact that
they're also often shy the people that
come across as extremely confident might
actually be just a little bit less
sensitive goes hand in hand with being a
little bit less shy and embarrassed to
approach someone out of the blue chances
are they maybe aren't quite so in their
own head so the nice guys the issue
isn't that they're nice is that they're
you know standing at the back of the
club and not approaching them girls and
when they do approach the girls they're
kind of timid about it so imagine that
instead of going up and being Brash and
cocky and putting a girl down to try and
look like this you know whatever
evolutionary Superior option or hiding
in the corner and sort of waving like
this and being the nice guy instead you
be The Confident nice guy you go up to
the group of girls or guys you introduce
yourself you don't have to just one
thing you just have a good time you chat
you buy drinks you have fun and then if
there is someone who catches your eye
towards the end of the night when you've
already established a rapport shown
yourself to be confident fun with their
friends you make your intentions known
by buying them their own drink or just
talking to them a bit more wouldn't that
be a far more effective way so the issue
is not that you're not aggressive enough
it's not that you don't have enough
muscle the issue is just that you need
to work on your confidence and maybe
practice hanging out with people and
maybe don't head out on a night out just
after one thing because that's a massive
turn off for anybody that's why I think
that just training to try and attract
members of the opposite sex isn't going
to work and apologies if that seems a
bit off topic but I think it's important
to keep in mind because I think the
reasons that we train can get quite deep
and complex I think there's this kind of
very complicated psychology that goes on
especially with young men who are trying
to find their way in the world and they
become attracted as a result to these
kind of aggressive and archetypal
masculine Concepts but again I think you
need to come at it from the right place
I think it's really important to
approach these goals in the right way
and for the right reasons because here's
the other thing I think for a lot of
guys there's a lot riding on their
ability to attract members of the
opposite sex they actually base an awful
lot of their self-worth and their
identity on their ability to you know
pull women or guys at the bar and if
they can't do this they feel like
failures and it goes beyond just wanting
sex guys have got this huge thing about
status and it's so evident when watching
YouTube and self-development stuff
spending huge inordinate amounts of time
changing your whole lifestyle to try and
look and project this sense of you know
high value males so that they can
attract members of the opposite sex not
only as I have said is this not going to
work because it's just trans apparently
desperate and it's inauthentic but at
the same time who cares it's not an
achievement in the same way that
climbing a mountain is an achievement or
running an ultra marathon or building an
app or anything else like that and of
course 99.9999 of you guys watching this
know all this but I think the problem is
that of the loudest voices on the
internet are you know pubescent to men I
don't think that changing nappies and
getting up at two o'clock in the morning
are the things that make me happy but I
know that deep down they are they're the
things that give my life meaning they're
the things that make me feel fulfilled
and it has nothing to do with status or
how successful I am because happiness is
true freedom and training to be fitter
and healthier and a better expression of
yourself that is the kind of training
that's going to make you happier same
time think about your goals think about
the things you want to achieve and the
kind of training that you enjoy for its
own sake whether that's running fast
because you like the feeling of the wind
in your hair climbing because you enjoy
the thrill of being high up or
calisthenics because you love how it
feels to perform a really cool move do
martial arts not because you want to
prove how hard you are and how you can
beat anyone in a fight because you want
to work on yourself and achieve the body
awareness that allows you to do cool
kicks because you want to be able to
move in an artistic and Powerful way or
because you enjoy the thrill of the
fight for its own sake not because you
have to win you'll perform so much
better if you can detach yourself from
that need to win from that status and
ego if you're a power lifter do it
because you enjoy struggling against a
heavy weight that feeling of being
underneath something that could crush
you a feeling of blasting through your
personal best through nothing other than
dedication hard work and patience not
because you want to beat the person next
to you and get a bigger lift than them
because that's the kind of thinking that
will cause you to take silly shortcuts
and ultimately injure yourself there
will always be someone stronger and if
you don't accept that you're going to
hurt yourself or just become really
angry and frustrated and there isn't
some point where you do this where you
lift this weight and then your life
becomes amazing and you become the alpha
and all the women throw themselves at
your feet that just doesn't happen to me
personally Fitness should be in a big
way about self-expression should be
about being you but the most you that
you can be and if you're training in a
way that's designed to impress other
people or that's trying to fit in with a
different group then of course this
isn't going to happen you're not going
to be training in a way that is true to
yourself and the irony is that if you
would try and train in a way that was
unique to you that is actually how you
would impress the most people okay guys
that's a bit of a rant but I hope that
you can take something from it I think
all of us are guilty at times of
training for the wrong reasons training
to impress other people training because
it's what we've always done as a part of
our identity training for ego when in
fact not only is it not impressing
anybody but it's ultimately only going
to hurt you it might hurt your gains it
might ultimately lead to you injuring
yourself because you are so desperate to
achieve something or to gain something
or prove something whereas if we just
take a patient approach if we enjoy the
process and if we train for us we'll get
far better results we'll get there
faster and we'll have more fun doing it
and we won't get hurt
what do you guys think why do you train
do you train to impress other people do
you train for yourself if you're
interested in comprehensive training
that addresses everything from strength
to Mobility to brain function and it
isn't just about what you look like but
how you truly feel and perform then you
might enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
the protein performance system comes
with over two hours of instructional
videos plus an 80 plus page ebook and
you can find that in the link in the
description down below either way guys
thank you so much for watching this one
and I'll see you next time bye for now